jamming the streets of bangkok
pro-democracy protesters out in strength
to show their support
of the growing call for the resignation
of prime minister
this is rooted in their deep criticism
of how the government has managed the
kovit-19 crisis
the nation is now facing its worst wave
of infections and deaths of the pandemic
the government has to ask itself when it
looks at the people who doesn't see
are with the same countrymen your job is
to serve the people do you see the value
of the people
one year ago a youth-led movement kicked
off calling for changes in the
long-established power structures here
in thailand
centered on the monarchy the military
and the elite connected to them
the prime minister is an ex-army chief
who first came to power in a coup
with a list of 10 demands they called
for deep reforms in the monarchy
a taboo subject here in thailand where
harsh laws aim to protect and preserve
the crown's powerful position but
discussion of what was once taboo
changed with the protests
i think the discussion on the thai
monarchy movement is moving in a better
direction
the issue is deep rooted in our society
and we should be able to discuss it in
public
earlier this year there were arrests of
the top protest organizers and a
crackdown by the police
the protests became less frequent and
fewer people came out
to regain momentum lost over the last
several months mainly because of covet
protest leadership have had to become
creative with their gatherings like this
car mob here in central bangkok but they
have also had to refocus their messaging
to appeal to a broader audience as some
don't fully support reforming the
monarchy right now organizers have
focused on their call
for the prime minister's resignation not
abandoning crown reform just tapping
people's frustration with the government
the democracy movement are seeing an
opportunity
to try to give
a a new flame
into that struggle by using the
government failure
to provide efficient vaccine
to provide efficient health care
and the flame appears to be growing with
a steady increase of covid19 infections
each day
and no indication that the shortage of
vaccines will be corrected soon
people will likely have more reason to
come out and call for change
scott heiler al jazeera bangkok